[Music]
the pewdiepie subreddit has finally hit
three million members
whoa if i got 3 million members on my
actual youtube channel i would make 15
million a month
for charity of course become a member
the money has been donated 89 000
to the yemen humanitarian crisis save
the children
thank you guys it's thanks to members
but that's not important right now
because we had three million members i
thought all right what's our ranking
85 i will not settle for 85.
the flip 85 not even top
50. god damn i'm not happy about this
this is
mildly infuriating yes suck it mildly
infuriating
guess you're not that infuriating after
all so i thought today you know i review
subreddits a lot
why don't we just go through one by one
the ones that are better than me or
think they are better than me
okay here we go photography this is our
number one enemy right now
photography why would anyone subscribe
to this garbage
honestly it is actually pretty garbage
i'm i'm confused
top voted today how in hundred
don't care next up that we have to beat
overwatch
does anyone still play overwatch cringe
was that cool was that supposed to be
cool i'm not impressed at all
cringe hey remember when uh back in 2018
everyone would refer to what their
interests as porn
food porn desktop porn g
fuel port it's poor it's all porn
apparently that's still a thing
3.1 get the [ __ ] out of here there's an
even
oh that looks delicious that looks like
pure carbs
you will not be in any porn if you eat
those am i right gamers get the [ __ ] out
of here
reaction gifts they can't be beating me
no no i will not be defeated by some
goddamn
2016 memes
that's it it's just reaction gifts
i'm better than i can make reaction
gifts
i was that yeah something for your
folder how about angry
oh no i unplugged my computer how did
that happen
god dammit what the [ __ ] how did that
happen there we go i'm back
you can use that as a confused computer
gif
here's a here's a look at that sim gif
[Music]
ten times better now unsubscribe from
reaction gifts
do it cringe whoa dude i never actually
heard of this subreddit it seems quite
popular
let's do per month actually really
impressed me do it all time
whoa dude whoa
huh ah
no what
frame rate synced with wings that's so
cool
whoa dude unsubscribe from this
subreddit it's not cool it's not cool
this piece of fuzz that doesn't want to
leave my what
oh my god whoa
that's black magic that is not whoa
that's magic
whoa oh my god i did the thing a
solar eclipse from a plane wow
i like this subreddit mad
skills
sick bro nah dude nah
[ __ ] up no that is not
real heavenly pit was deepest sinkhole
in china
what ah that's a pit i'll dip
in if you know what i mean gamer
[Music]
gamers hey look it's a girl next to her
art
all right confirmed confirmed whoa do
subreddit full of ships
dude cringe dude correct oh my god i'm
cringing so hard
got a chance all right i'm not subbing
to it everything
tattoo who has tattoos dude cringe
don't sub to this animals just being
bros
animals are not our friends stop trying
to pretend you have friends you have no
friends oh that is adorable
i love that
that is so cute my gosh
they are totally friends just sitting on
a park bench
that's incredible
what is this
oh my god they found their new mommy
see this just proves my point animals
are not our friends
it's the same bench he came back
that's so cute oh
i hate the subreddit zero out of ten
nba more like not i got ball and i got
black and i got no other word for b
what's wrong with me bouncy no
it just sucks okay and not because of
those words i
said playstation 4 cringe outdated
console
unsub now how did i get here what is
this
daddy what did you do during the erosion
of our democracy i shared some white hot
memes with a small group of like-minded
friends
therefore no tattoos thanks my body is a
temple
temples
[Laughter]
nice
he said licking rat was his right
it's my goddamn riding privilege
that's funny that's hilarious ah repost
cringe
cringe not funny anymore pewdiepie
subreddit
no repos unsub from this sub to
pewdiepie subreddit spongebob means be
3.4 really spongebob's meme
i'm okay with this that's fine you get
to live spongebob meme
but not for long what's next minecraft
you get to live minecraft
but only because of sven relationship
advice i give the best relationship
advice
never interact with anyone next unsub
from this
all right let's see all right should i
help someone my 22 vegan girlfriend
wants me to get
rid of my cat what the [ __ ]
my girlfriend is a passionate vegan and
wants me to get rid of my beloved cat
because cats eat me
[Laughter]
get rid of your girlfriend they said
simple my god
first of all let me see what you can't
make can't stop
eating mice
we need to cancel all carnivorous
animals
because they eat meat can you believe
this [ __ ]
oh my god
what could go wrong i kind of like this
idea
because first of all we get to see
people do something stupid
this is what i think at least i've never
seen it but then we get to see them
suffering the consequences of that
action while live streaming you
introduce your cat
what could go wrong i wrote her in today
because i'm telling you she's a better
whoa oh ow ow oh my pp hurt
[Music]
that was awful is he okay hey man if you
got a small pb
just join pewdiepie subreddit problem
solved
wait wait wait dank memes
dank memes got us beat dude what the
[ __ ] everything about tinder what
what i've never done a tinder maybe i
should do a full video on this
is it funny are you lightning because i
want to make you my queen
hi obviously i'm no longer in i'm no
linger interest
dead in communicating with you after
that message but i'm writing to let you
know
entirely for your own sake that you need
to do better
or no girl will ever seriously reply to
you
but you just replied i think point
proven wrong
christine each
and diagram i'm just kidding all right
wtf
six million what why that's a wtf moment
right there there's no way they're
better what do they got
[Laughter]
when the european settlers arrived they
needed land to live on they had no land
the first nation people agreed to move
to different
areas to make room for new settlements
how nice of them to do
so wow history is so interesting
i like this subreddit very nice this one
gets to live
interesting as [ __ ] all right i'll be
the judge of that mr i swore in title
cringe
you put you put swore in title you
you're immediately cringed and i don't
even care
all right so apparently
these wavy patterns of bricks uses less
bricks
because they are structurally more
stronger uh
if you do it flat you would need more
bricks because you need to double the
layer
that's the point of this image are you
impressed i'm not
not interesting at all oh my god that
took me a while jeez
that's pretty dope a special effects
artist made himself a mask for the
pandemic and i can't get over it
that okay that's pretty cool i'll give
you that one
that's insane how is it so preserved
no that can't be real i don't believe it
fake news
sorry interesting you're not interesting
best subreddit well why
isn't just pewdiepie submissions here
what the hell
travel why would you travel anywhere
cringe
oddly satisfying i do like this one
[Laughter]
whoa oh
this is what happens when you get peepee
small
damn never thought we'd catch it live on
camera
that is oddly satisfying though league
of legends no one plays that anymore god
damn it
face palm you get to live selfish of the
soul i've actually never heard of this
oh it's me irl come on oh look they have
that's that big fine life hack
using google translate oh you can put
google translate
in oh
oh what
that's so cool i mean no i don't need
this at all
terrible advice life hack more like life
give me my life back because you wasted
my time
nature is [ __ ] like never heard of
this one either
but lucas saves an iphone what
no way the beluga
that's so nice here you go
i know they're expensive sorry about
your iphone bro i got it right here
huh no same whale found
35 years damn
it looks painted almost what is it
i'm so confused yeah nature is not
important
very overrated pc masteries uh cringe
just cringe fitness you get to live our
philosophy is quite high that makes me
happy
what the hell that's unexpected
philosophy is higher than memes
the [ __ ] whoa photoshop battles what the
[ __ ]
no one went there i don't believe that
how did they get so many followers
they must have bought followers for all
things creepy
a friend went for a walk the other night
and saw this woman just
whoa god that's so creepy which is
supporting the subreddit but i still
what the hell
the top map shows mysterious cases of
people vanishing without a trace
the bottom map shows america's largest
cave systems
no cave people are
real i should not be joking but uh
no no whoa
that looks so real i don't like it stop
it
artist with dementia whoa
whoa the [ __ ]
old lady with a knife scene on doorbell
cam in the middle of the night
what the [ __ ] just bought a house
find this in the basement seal tight oh
god no
god that makes me feel uncomfortable
next one who
else do we gotta beat personal finance
what the hell people care more about
personal
finance than pewdiepie subreddit what
the flipped out
old school cool the paramount pictures
logo on the day was originally painted
in 1965 that is actually cool
fine my dad with david bowie in vacation
what the [ __ ] my dad front and nom
didn't know this photo existed came
across randomly internet he cried when
he saw it
hope this is the right place to post it
god damn
she built the bike god damn fine
we may not be cool at the pewdiepie
running but
yeah that's it that's all we get future
studies what is that
elon musk we know we'll run out of dead
dinosaurs to mine for fuel and
have to use sustainable energy
eventually so why not go renewable now
and avoid uh increasing risk of climate
cat
catastrophe betting that science is
wrong and all companies
are right is the dumbest experiment in
history by far well he does have a point
doesn't he
data is beautiful i'll be the judge of
that all right what do we got
trending google searches by state logan
paul fortnite
what no way this is so interesting so
this is 2018.
cardi b
[Music]
logan paul holy [ __ ] holy
oh the new show came out sean oh no
black panther fortnite back baby
chloe almost bill cosby wow
royal wedding american night fortnight
get the [ __ ] out for tonight oh my god
stop it for tonight
stop it for now no
fortnight it's all for not a ball what
do you
know oh this is so interesting
baby shark you almost did it the
haunting of the hill house
oh my god baby shark stanley
rest in peace man ah [ __ ] off
fortnite why is this so annoying
jesus
okay let me guess it's gonna go back to
fortnite
i don't know what these like oh justice
molly yeah
captain marvel
really seems like one trending topic
takes over everything but i suppose that
makes sense anyway
now i just kind of miss fortnight i'm
not gonna lie
area 51. snooking for yes
yes yeah whoa joking for a long time oh
my god billy alice jesus [ __ ] up
mandalorian baby then came baby yoda
oh man okay i wonder if i've ever been
the top search jojo rabbit was good
that is super interesting i quite like
that
that is beautiful i was wrong i wonder
what you get out of that
reddit philosophy this is the top voted
of all time
oh my god socrates is in the new
assassin's creed
that's so epic i love philosophy
all right that's about it i can stomach
for this video
subscribe to pewdiepie submission god
damn it
do it now now thank you for liking
subscribing and all that
thanks 406 million subscribers i have
not put the tambourine yet
leave a comment what to put on
tambourine and i see you guys tomorrow
hey hey ah children of
nine parts it's time to raise what was
once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pvp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]
foreign